welcome everyone how is everyone feeling
about the world's best developer
conference so far great yeah I think we
should give them all our big applaud
excellent I love this conference I love
coming here
it's not too far I'm from Gothenburg so
it's not gonna afford to travel so did
anyone come here to listen about VB
that's good I have a few things to say
about VB but let's keep that for later
we're going to talk a little bit a
little bit about the state of C sharp so
C sharp has changed a lot over the past
few years over the past ten years so
we're gonna cover a lot of the features
that you've missed we're gonna talk
about things that might be coming in the
next versions things that Microsoft have
been talking about adding to the
language for a long time that they
didn't so we'll talk a little bit about
why they might not have added that all
right so is everyone in here a c-sharp
developer if you're not raise your hand
ha gotcha all right so my name is
Phillip Ekberg I'm a Microsoft MVP it
means that I talk about Microsoft stuff
but I'm not really employed by Microsoft
so I kind of free free marketing so I
wrote a book called c-sharp smorgasbord
that's available for free on my blog so
just head over to my blog and download
that if you want it's been out for a few
years I cover a few language features
like async and dynamic and how to write
good code all right so enough about me
and about my book we're gonna talk about
the best language in the world which is
C sharp so C sharp is kind of this mix
of all the different paradigms out there
we have declarative programming
languages imperative programming
languages and functional programming
languages and c-sharp tries to steal all
features from all of them or borrow I
don't know whichever makes you feel good
so they take things from F sharp and
they take things from Coughlin's and
Swift and Java and and all those
different other languages out there and
kind of make that as a part of the
c-sharp experience and I think that's
what makes c-sharp one of the best
languages out there and if we just go
back over the years I want to quickly
recap some of the things
was added to c-sharp after the first
version so c-sharp one you know we got
if statements and switches and for loops
and whatever all the other normal
programming languages at that time had
right so but after that release we kind
of got c-sharp 2.0 which added generics
and partial types in anonymous methods
iterators and nullable types and so
forth so this was kind of heaven for
developers because I came from a Java
background and having worked in Java
coming to C sharp and do generic
programming was really great was one of
the the things that kind of made me
stick to c-sharp alright so this was a
great addition to the language but the
next addition to c-sharp which was
c-sharp 3 we got implicitly typed local
variables and a funny story here is that
when they introduced this in the
language I've had this discussion so
many times with developers over the
years they thought that just because you
didn't add the type at the start c-sharp
was now a dynamic programming language
which is not kind of the thing right so
just being able to write bar X is equal
to 10 doesn't mean that it's dynamically
typed so it took a few years before well
maybe a few months before few people got
that after c-sharp 3 was released and
then we got auto property initializer
synonymous message extension methods and
query expressions and so forth things
that kind of led up to us being in this
more functional environment we can now
write linked expressions and we can do
all types of craziness that kind of
builds up this language into being even
more expressive than it was before
things like generics in c-sharp 2 came
from research at Microsoft when they did
that for f-sharp so they took those bits
and added that into c-sharp and kind of
the same goes for the features that they
had in c-sharp 3 which they kind of took
from other places as well so they all
kind of take these different ideas from
each other and now those two the
languages we're gonna spend too much
time talking about the old versions
because everyone in here probably knows
a little bit about all these different
features now something interesting
happened with c-sharp 4 we only got a
handful of nice features now not trying
to say that the team didn't work well on
adding things to find
which but I mean come on what three
features I want this huge list of things
added to the programming language that's
why choose c-sharp so we've got dynamic
binding so finally we were able to write
dynamic programming in C sharp which
meant that we could now do things like
iron Python and iron Jas and we could
write things in a more dynamic manner we
could write scripting in our
applications and have that evaluated at
runtime that's pretty cool and then we
got C sharp 5 with only pretty much one
feature I love async is one of those
things that being keep keeping me
employed for the past few years because
everyone gets it wrong and I need to go
in and help them understand asynchronous
programming so I think it's great that
they add asynchronous methods to c-sharp
but they've made it so easy for
developers to add async code that they
kind of forgot about how hard it is to
write his interest programming so if we
look at these different iterations of
the programming language the second
iteration we got a lot of features the
third we got a lot of features then we
got less and then we got less you'd
expect that c-sharp 6 added just like a
handful of features the problem here is
that by this time the compiler was
probably what 8 10 12 years old 13 years
old and written in C++ I don't know if
anyone in here has worked on a 10 plus
year old project written in C++ can't
really be one awesome Oh actually a lot
that's awesome so you probably know that
it's hard to maintain those apps and
adding new things to those that kind of
fundamentally changed behavior they need
to do a lot of things in the compiler to
make a symptoms methods work right so
that kind of makes it difficult so at
this point they had already announced
that they were rewriting all the
compilers so does anyone not know what
rosslyn is a few you don't know what
trust me so Roslyn is this project that
Microsoft called it it's really the the
microsoft.net compiler platform so what
they did was they they took the
compilers they looked at it and felt
like we need to rewrite this in
something better than C++ so they
rewrote the c-sharp come
hollering c-sharp which is pretty cool
so they used the old compiler to compile
the new compiler now what do you do with
bugs in the old compiler do you bring
them across to the new compiler as well
you probably have to because it needs to
be able to compile no lapse and if you
break old apps that means that the
compiler is not really that good right
so they had to re-implement all the bugs
in the old compiler which probably feels
horrible to a developer no knowingly
adding blocks to your code but that's
what they had to do so they started
rebuilding the compilers which is
rosslyn the idea here is that they can
now add more language features a lot
more easily so how do we make it even
more easier for us to add features to
the language one of the problems that
Java had over the years is that they had
this language design team that was
sitting in a cave somewhere talking
about features they want to add to the
language ten years in the future they
didn't talk to anyone else until they
released that version of Java that's
kind of problematic you're not very
agile right so what Microsoft did was
that they released the compilers as an
open source project so if you go to
github you go to dotnet slash rosslyn
you can see here that there's 35,000 or
36,000 commits to the the.net compilers
or they rosslyn compiler so this
compiles both c-sharp and VB it does all
the code analysis so what you can do
with this is that you can bring that
into your application and you can point
to a c-sharp file and have that compiled
by your app this means that you can get
scripting with c-sharp and you can do
all kinds of crazy things with the
compiler now they've done 91 releases
you know there's not 91 releases of
Visual Studio that would be crazy right
but what you can do is that you can go
into the releases here you can download
a version of the compiler and just bring
that into Visual Studio or you start as
a nougat package in your app and write
your own IDE for instance I think that's
pretty cool and working in an
open-source environment means that we
don't only want the code out there so I
think Apple has done kind of open source
for a long time but the way they do it
is that
develop everything internally and then
just publish the code which is kind of
the wrong approach as well so you'll see
here there's 4700 issues I wouldn't want
to be the PM that has to arrange all
those different issues and prioritize
but a lot of people spend time adding
issues to the compiler or adding feature
requests
I think bugs to reporting bugs here
which is great so this kind of opens up
for this dialogue with other developers
all right so they have a lot of pull
requests I've actually gonna pull a
request to the compiler github
repositories my face is in there I
updated a spelling mistake in a document
so yeah for that I didn't get anything
though so oh well what they also do is
that they post all their c-sharp design
guidelines or their their c-sharp design
notes so match that the keynote this
morning he's posting a lot of the
internal discussions they have here so
when they're at Microsoft they talk
about the language features and they add
their meeting notes to github people can
pitch in and talk about ideas on
features that they want added to the
programming language and I think this is
a great way for the language to evolve
but it also means that there's so much
noise from the community about features
that we we might want to have in the
programming language here's an example
so we can see sharp 7 we've got tuples
or better tuples language support for
samples rather and this proposal was up
already in 2015 and they're just added
that a few releases to go ago to to the
c-sharp compilers so they talked about
why they want to add this to have a lot
of mathematical information about how to
implement this in the implications to
the programming language and know people
spend so much time talking about the
language features which is great because
it helps us as developers we don't have
to worry too much about that so
introducing Rosling opening up for other
people to write things in the compiler
and for Microsoft work with is openly
means that they can now add features to
all the different programming languages
a lot quicker this means that we want to
add features to a language that most
people kind of leverage which is C sharp
so that means there's no more language
parody previously what happened was that
we have a feature in c-sharp and it's
also available most of the times in VB
if it's in V beats probably in c-sharp
there's very few things in VB that I
would like to have in c-sharp except the
XML literals but they've always been the
parody between these languages but
that's not the case anymore so what
happens now is that they might add
things like pattern matching to C sharp
which is not available in VB yet but
there's still a ton of VB developers out
there so they will probably add that who
knows in the future so now we've kind of
come to the point where we're gonna talk
about pretty much the current state it's
anyone in here not not familiar with
c-sharp six most of you are familiar
with c-sharp six it's it was released a
while ago
so we'll quickly grow through these
different language features and just
have a look at the different ones I'll
just
I have features listed for all the
different c-sharp iterations and we'll
jump into Visual Studio and have a look
at them and talk through these different
features and if you have any questions
just throw something at me not your
laptop cuz that hurts so we got using
statements for static members which
means that we can now be a little bit we
can use less characters when we use a
lot of static types we've got Auto
property initializers the idea here is
that we can now use proper read-only
auto properties previously it was really
hard for us to introduce our auto
property that you only set once during
your application all right we can do
have weights inside catch him finally
blocks we got the null conditional
operator that's probably one of the best
features in c-sharp six string
interpolation that's really handy we no
longer have to do string dot format just
dust that underneath for us Dictionary
initializers we got expression buried
body mass of members and exception
filters and as well as the name of
operator like this list here that's why
as you see sharp right because they add
all these different language features
that helped me save characters
so does everyone in here knows Scott
Hanselman is he did a joke once I don't
know if he was a joke but he said that
we only have a certain amount of
keystrokes in our lives and I think that
the c-sharp team they can spend as many
keystrokes as they want as long as I
don't have to spend them right so if I
can save up a few characters when I
write my c-sharp code that's really
great so we have this solution here I
have language features from all
different versions of c-sharp and we go
through all of them so the first one is
using stated statements for static
members it's super simple we'll go
through them quickly what we do here is
that I no longer have to say console dot
write line at the top here I can say
well I want to use all the static
members from this class I could do the
same thing for for math for instance our
case a using static system dot math and
I would then be able to say PI instead
of doing math dot pi and of course if I
introduce a method in here
in this context called write line that
takes the same parameter that one wins
instead of console dot write line which
makes sense so it's saying the same
resolution as I've done before and we
also see the name of operator here which
is kind of a great addition what they do
here is that they simply allow us to say
well you have this type here I want you
to get the name of that type and why is
that important because for too often in
error messages you've forgotten to
refactor the name inside the error
message of the type that was a problem
so this here will allow us to when we
refactor program to something else
you'll just reflect on all the different
places and we're also seeing that we're
doing string interpolation here so
previously we've been able to do an @
sign here to allow us to to do certain
things inside the string but now we can
do this dollar sign which is allowing us
to say well inside these curly braces
here I'm gonna have something that
evaluates as a code block so we could
say ten year for instance or we could
say var X is equal to ten and we could
say X in here all right super simple
so we no longer have to worry about that
straightened out format and the order of
things when we do me string that format
all right so the auto property
initializers which is the next cool
feature in this case here I've got this
string property called name here and I'm
setting that to the initial value of
Phillip so this here is a true reading
all the auto property if I try to set
that down here it'll tell us that this
here is actually read-only so he can't
do that so that's kind of a nice
addition now one of the things I really
love about c-sharp is how easy it is for
us to do a synchronous code but one of
the problems prior to c-sharp 6 was that
we couldn't do awaits in slide caches
and finally blocks so very often you
want to clean up after yourself or add
something to a database and do that as
synchronously and you couldn't do that
before so in this case here I have this
run a sync block here it catches on
exception and then inside the exception
when I clean up and then I maybe I want
to dispatch a message somewhere and so
forth right but of course then what
happens is well if this throws here you
would probably have to have that as an
inside a catch block as well and you
would just end up in this mess
but it's nice that it's there now
probably one of the best features added
to c-sharp six is the new conditional
operators so one of the things that
working heavily on both in c-sharp 6 and
C sharp 7 & 8 and probably 9 and 10 as
well is that they want to avoid as
having no reference exceptions now
adding null to a language is probably
one of the worst design decisions ever
because I don't know everyone in the air
probably got a little reference
exception sometime languages like
Coughlin's and swift everything is not
nullable not know by default which means
that you have to be very explicit when
something can be null which means that
it's really hard for the application to
just suddenly throw an old reference
exception those languages do other weird
things about anyways so what we can do
here is that I have this array off
person here it's null because it's not
initialise we can just imagine that it's
retrieved from somewhere I can say here
well I want to grab other people and if
this arrays not no I want you to give me
the the first item in the list of people
if that's not no I want you to give me
the name of that person what happens
here is that if one of these things are
no when we're doing this no conditional
operator this entire block here
evaluates to no itself so then we can
use this thing here to say well if any
of these are null we'll just default to
this value which is kind of nice right
and you'll see here the same at the
bottom here we say well if person is not
null give me the name if the if any of
that is no just say unknown if the
person is it's not now give me the
address if the address is not null give
in the street it's pretty simple now in
reality your code now looks like it's
question marks everywhere and that you
don't know what you want so it's a
trade-off right so expression bodied
members it's one of those additions that
kind of didn't make sense to me from the
start but the more I use it the more I
like it in this case here at the bottom
I'm overriding to string and I'm simply
saying well I want to return something
so instead of me having to write a lot
of code to to do that whoops
so instead of me having to write the
method body here which would be return
name right I can just do that expression
body member less characters that's all
that matters right looks pretty nice
super simple addition and then finally
the language feature I want to talk
about is its exception filters so with
exceptions you know when you want to
catch an exception you want to say well
I will catch the network operation timed
out exception only when the status code
or whatever I'm looking at is something
what you had to do
previously was to say well I want to
catch that exception and then have an if
block inside that which kind of ended up
being a little bit nasty so now we can
say well I want to create a new HTTP
client I want to do this call to Google
comm when I get a web exception and the
the web exception state is is timeout
I'm gonna retry but if the name
resolution fails well that means that I
don't have internet connection for
instance means that I can't do a DNS
check right so this is kind of nice and
you'll see later that they've reused the
one keyword in other places all right so
let's just head back to and talk a
little bit about c-sharp seven so
c-sharp 6 added a lot of nice features
and that's kind of one of the powers off
Ross Lee and they had really easy it was
released for them to add features to the
language especially now that the
compilers were rewritten so what is
there in c-sharp that's missing a lot of
things for instance tuples and
deconstruction I don't know if anyone in
here has worked in other programming
languages where tuples is kind of a
first-class citizen it's one of those
things that just makes sense when you
have it in your code it makes things
like pattern matching a lot easier and
it makes the code look a lot more
beautiful which is kind of what we want
so they also added pattern matching or a
first attempt to pattern matching
there's a heap of improvements coming to
the pattern pattern matching stuff but
at least it's in their digit separators
in binary literals local functions
that's pretty cool as well riff returns
that is some improvements to the out
parameter so these aren't kind of a heap
of features but things like topples and
pattern matching that's no easy thing to
solve so it probably took a long time to
add that to the language so let's look
at the code for this so we're past the
sharp six we're going to look at tuples
this is a tuple pretty much multiple
return types or a way for us to express
ourselves and say well I have this thing
here just create the type for me so we
have these two things
to integers that I want to return for my
get point here and I return hundred and
two hundred that's automatically
injected into the X into the Y okay
that's pretty cool so when I use that I
can I can kind of deconstruct that in
different ways as well so I can say I
want to get the point I want to map the
tupple that we got from from get point
here into these two different local
parameters but I could also say well I
want you to map those just automatically
and see that the code here still works
doesn't show up anything because what
happens is that we can say points point
dot X and point out why and of course if
we just undo that I could say point X
and point Y and now the application
doesn't work anymore because I've
deconstructed that into two different
local parameters with two different
names as you see at the bottom as well
so this kind of helps us when it comes
to pattern matching and you only see why
when we talk a little bit more about
c-sharp eight so this is kind of one of
those things that they add to the
language because it's gonna be nice
along the way it's something that they
need to have in the language in order
for him to add more cool things all
right so that's tuples super simple
really what they do is that they map to
I think you can cast that to a to a
tuple as well and this here will allow
you to do item 1 and item 2 was well
under the hood so they do a bit of magic
there as well if you worked with your
old tuples that is alright so pattern
matching is one of those things that's
kind of hard sometimes to give you a
head around the idea is that in this
case here I have an abstract class
called shape I have a triangle and a
rectangle and I know that inside my
program somewhere I get this thing
called the shape I don't know which
shape it is I don't know if it's a path
it's a rectangle a circle or a triangle
so I want to say well depending on the
type give me the correct type and give
me that as a local parameter without me
having to cast anything anywhere
so what we do is that well I'm gonna
create a new shape here you see that I'm
this is a strong it's the type shape
I used to switch block and say well when
this is say triangle
give me that as a local variable T here
so that means in this context in here I
can use all the properties that I have
on my tranq triangle and down here at
the rectangle if it's a rectangle I'll
get that as well all right so that's
pretty neat and one of the the places we
use this in other languages so I'm doing
a bit of coughing at the moment and they
do pattern matching everywhere one of
the ways that we can do this is by
saying well I do a call to our web
server and the the result is then
transformed into the correct object or
into an error so I can say well if it's
either the error or if it's the correct
data container I know what to do in my
app so you can do pattern matching to
find out kind of where to go in your app
as well I think it's super powerful
local functions and binary literals I
don't know if I remember if we're gonna
use this
so the digit separators allows us to
just add a lot of underscores everywhere
I don't know why I would do that I don't
really write numbers like this if I want
to write the number 16 I just do this so
I mean I guess if you're a game
developer or you want to impress on
someone I know
alright so local functions I have this
function called calculate down here
which is an internal or local function
called fibonacci so this returns to
Fibonacci of X and this is kind of nice
if you want to have a you don't want to
leak something out to an outer method or
if you just want to decompress something
or you want to do something very
specific in that context I think it's
pretty cool I haven't really used to get
though again if you're a game developer
you probably do a lot of refs and an out
parameters and you want to optimize all
the different types and references and
passing objects and values and reference
types and and so forth everywhere in
your app in this case here I have this
local function called element at it
takes
this array that a cola source take the
position and then it returns a reference
to a certain position in this right so
what happens down here is that I'm
saying well I want to give the give me
the the reference to the element at the
first index which is kind of the same
way of saying this here right it's kind
of odd looking at this code here and
that it's not that it's compiling and
that it's all good right because it
looks kind of weird and it is weird I
wouldn't want to see this in production
but this here kind of illustrates that
what I'm doing here is that I'm saying
well just give me the reference to that
integer it doesn't matter where it is it
doesn't matter if it's on the stack or
the heap or wherever it is just give me
a reference to that and I can then set
the value myself right it's great if you
don't want to pass the reference this or
copy values and so forth
again if you're a kind of game developer
and you have all these or if you work a
lot with in Rob's you have out
parameters everywhere they've done a lot
of improvements or one improvement
that's really great so you no longer
have to say you no longer have to do
this no longer have to write this now
what you can do say well I want you to
create the variable yourself if the
variable will set yeah so that's pretty
cool so you can do that in one line I
had a chat with a developer maybe a long
time ago maybe eight years ago and he
said well why is there no way for you to
do this like it makes so much sense we
don't have everything on one line and it
took 10 years for them to add this
through the compiler so I mean most have
been a really hard feature to implement
I don't know all right
so c-sharp 7.1 this is the first time
that Microsoft did point releases so 7.1
was one of those things that well why
don't we call it eight well maybe
because there's no substantial features
we just want to add a little sugar to
the language and that's one of the
things they can do with the power of
ralston right they can just when they
ship an update to visual studio they can
also
add some language features that no one
really maybe knows about so c-sharp 7.1
we finally got a way for us to say that
we have an asynchronous main method this
means that if you write console apps
that consume things that are in a
database or on the web you don't have to
wrap it in a task start run and then do
not wait because that's just horrible
and if anyone's looking at that code
they will be like wow this is gonna
deadlock cuz all that don't really
deadlock but they probably would say
that with a default expression which is
another way for us to just save a few
characters we can infer the tupple names
pattern matching with generics ref
assemblies and just let's just look at
two of them they've got 7.1 minor
release didn't add too many cool things
so what we have here is we have this
main method here I've marked that as an
async method and it's returning a task
and it just works as a normal console
app so if I run this it'll delay the the
console for Capone it'll delay for one
second and then say wow and then it's
done so don't eat any weird things in
here just works out of the box if we
turn on 7.1 which would probably be
default now and this here is the new
default keyword previously you had to
say well I want the default of shape
which would be returning null right but
now kind of that's redundant to say well
I have the type here just give me the
default of that type they can just infer
that instead kind of makes sense all
right and then of course we can infer
the table names we talked about this
before I kind of sneak sneak peek into
this in in the previous demo because I
had a bumped up the language version so
you can actually go into the project and
doing to the ciaz project and change the
language version that you want to
support so let me see if I can and just
show you that
so you can say here well I want to use
language version 27.2 or the latest and
that'll just use the latest you have
installed which is kind of nice but one
of the things that they're doing with
the compilers is right there they're
changing behavior to things that compile
and maybe there's a breaking change and
you're not ready to jump on to the next
version of c-sharp so let's just we
don't need to jump into the PowerPoint
let's just jump into Visual Studio we'll
look at the the additions 27.2 because
there's not a lot so another point
release they added ref read-only in in
parameters so again this is one of those
things that if you work with high
performance applications or games or or
a lot of Interop you might want to do
this so what we're doing here is that we
are saying that well I want to return a
read-only reference so you get a
reference to that particular object
which is super quick to return from that
method but you can't change it
references have always been able to be
modified in the past but now we can say
well I I want to return a read-only
reference and together with that we get
this thing called the in parameter which
kind of restrict us to what we can do
with that it's kind of the same thing as
a read-only reference so what happens
here is that well I want to get a
parameter passed into this method as a
reference and you're not able to change
it so if I try to set Y to something
here it'll just break and say well
you're not really supposed to do that
it'll tell us that you can't reassign
that because if we don't we okay
and the in herre if you're calling this
method the the in keyword is kind of
redundant
you still need to pass it as a reference
if you do ref x here but when you're
juicing using the in keyword it's kind
of redundant to say well this is a
read-only thing you can just trust them
here it's kind of makes more sense for
you pass it as a reference because then
you were saying well anyone can change
this value
which is kind of dangerous in some cases
one of the other changes they did in 7.2
is that they now allow us to do non
trailing named arguments which just get
rid of this here you'll see that I have
X : ref X here right and previously
you'd have to have to say well Y is
equal to 210 for instance but now you
don't have to do that if you follow
those parameters after the first one
right kind of nice another thing they
introduced in R in 7.2 and in.net Cora
bleah 2.1 is the ability to spans so
everyone know what's spanis or does
anyone know what the span is oh not a
lot that's awesome
so span allows us to look at a set of
memory think of it as just saying well
just allowing me to look at this thing
here on the stack or the heap so in this
case here I'm saying well I have a an
array of integers that I initialize on
my stack so this is also an introduced
introduction in 7.2 where they say well
you can now use stack a lock without
marking this as unsafe so previously you
had to mark your code as unsafe when you
did this but here I'm saying well I want
to allocate an array of 100 integers on
my stack and the span here allows me to
look at that piece of the memory and
then I can do operations on that which
is super quick I can say well tickets
here I want to I want to slice that from
the from the middle and just to the end
and this gives me a new span that's yeah
I do in the bottom as well but it
doesn't actually cut up the array so you
know when you do
array dot take while or when you do a
substring it just copies all the values
in this case here you just get a
reference to that particular part of
memory so it doesn't actually initialize
anything more than this object here that
points to that particular set
memory which allows you to do really
crazy things in high performing
operations alright
I don't know if you've seen things added
to dotnet core into asp.net core but I
know that the asp.net team is heavily
using this to optimize memory usage and
doing all kinds of crazy things in the
transport and and all the different
memory operations okay so this is kind
of the current state we were at 7.3 now
but what's next of c-sharp like what one
of the these things they're all pretty
cool there there have been added to the
language over the past year or two but
there's still a long way to go to kind
of get features from Kathleen and Swift
and and I don't know if javis caught up
with generics yet but I know Causton has
generics which is great but there's so
many good things in other programming
languages that we want to bring into
c-sharp as well so again if we head over
to github there's this language features
Status page where they list all the
different statuses and that's actually
my face that's due my contribution to
the c-sharp compiler so they have this
page here where they're lists all the
different language features and the
status of them you can read all the
documentation about well how do we
implement this
what's the problems if we do it
different ways they have this c-sharp 8
or 8.0 candidate where you see that
there's it's only 3% completed there's a
lot of open issues 28 open issues that's
all the features they want added to the
language right I don't expect all of
these different things being added to to
c-sharp a but if we look at it like we
have C sharp 8 and 9 and we will
probably have eight point one eight
point two eight point three and we'll
probably have more seven pointers as
well it would be cool if they call it
c-sharp X it's because everyone else
seems to call things X when it's 10 one
of these days they're gonna add ranges
which is another way for us to kind of
talk about a subset of data or or or
grab things out of princess's span here
we can say well I want to grab a certain
range and I want a pattern that I can
express this with we're gonna get a sing
stream scent and I'm number voles which
is another way for us to work with
asynchronous code in our apps I'm gonna
get record types a record types is one
of those things they've talked about
since c-sharp 7 I love the idea of
adding record types and we'll look at
what this will look like if they do add
it but they've kind of scratched it
every time they release a new version of
the language and it's right now I feel
like they're never gonna add record
types but we'll see you know a default
method in a default interface methods
nullable reference types no listing
assignment recursive patterns and
pattern matching improvements negated
condition if statements no conditional
weight and a lot more so this list here
is kind of comprehensive right and
there's 28 more things that you can read
on github about what's coming to C sharp
8 right but some of the things that
they're adding to the language they do
as previews so we can have a look at did
I miss talked about 7 points freeze or
about that skip too many slides so
Before we jump into eight point zero I'm
gonna jump back here this is a few
really quick features they've at the top
of the quality which now allow us to say
well I'm getting a topple out of here
which is X & Y and we can now compare
that to two different values so I can
say well I have this thing here it's not
really the same topple it's not the same
reference it just matches the values in
the topples itself which is kind of nice
to have okay
I'm not sure I would ever use this but
they they've kind of made constraints on
generics less restrictive so in this
case here I can say well I want to have
a generic constraint that's an enum or
you can have a delegate or we can have
whatever you want in here and those
constraints were not possible before
there's probably a lot of cases where
you would use this
generic types itself is really really
great
and then of course they've added this
stack stack outlook initializer because
I have initialized switch for everything
else so stock outlook it's just a way
for us to just allocate things on the
stack super handy all right so enough
about the old stuff let's talk about
c-sharp aid one of the things that they
were gonna add is ranges ranges is this
way of for us to kind of describe that I
want a subset of data so you'll see here
that I'm saying I'm allocating these
numbers on my stack and then I represent
this as a span so I just get a reference
to that memory stream or that part of
the memory and then I say well I want to
give give me a slice of that memory I
want you to start at number element
number five and then just give me
everything else okay so if I run that
well if I don't close it first let's run
that again I run this
let's see if it's the right project
let's run that it'll say six seven eight
nine ten all right
so it started over here element number
five and then went to the end now this
expression here can be interesting so I
can say well just give me five to six or
five to seven I'll run that again and of
course that should just work gives me
two numbers or I can say well I want you
to give me everything from the end and
then minus one all right let's give me
six to nine so that's pretty handy
especially if you're working with large
subsets of data if you have this large
collection of things anyone say well I
want to give give me the subset of the
thing in the middle this is one of the
things that have been missing from
Python for instance it's one of those
things that I use a lot you could even
use it for when you initialize an array
for instance say well I want you to or
when you grab data you say well I want
from the start to the end ish and this
here allows us to say that and you can
even start at the end where you could
say like that kind of just looks like an
emoji but it just works all right that's
pretty cool since this kind of this is a
preview thing I had to install a new
version of the rosslyn compiler and had
to bring in this thing that implements a
lot of weird stuff that implements all
of range stuff but we're not gonna look
at that just want to mention that this
is not a visual studio yet so this is
just a preview thing that they might be
adding hopefully soon because I think
this is good all right so the ranges is
great that's a great addition to the
language now let's see if we're all
still awake we're gonna talk a little
bit more about pattern matching pattern
matching is great and it's something
that well it can improve a little bit so
this case here this kind of doesn't look
like any c-sharp
that I've ever written before so what
i'm doing here saying well i'm gonna
return a string from this method here
i'm gonna return something based on this
shape it's gonna run a switch statement
it's gonna switch on the shape if the
shape is a triangle only when T a and B
is not equal it's gonna give that
actually this will match when NB is not
equal and then they've introduced this
thing called recursive patterns which is
this thing here
which is kind of a mess to explain so
what happens here is that triangle if
you look at the type itself triangle is
a shape has a B and C a shape has a
point all of these different types have
specified something called a deconstruct
which is one of the things that they've
made improvements to you when they
introduce tuples so you can deconstruct
objects what we were simply saying here
is that when you call the deconstruct it
just outs a B and C in point that allows
you to get a copy right sort of so what
I'm doing here is I'm saying well give
me a triangle I want to map the values
from a deconstruct to a b c and then i
want to map the point because the point
is the the last parameter in my
deconstruct i want to map the point but
i don't care about the first value and i
want you to introduce a local variable Y
for the Y position ok did I just lose
everyone all right so that's kind of a
mouthful right and then I can just match
a rectangle whenever it's a rectangle
that's probably the simplest simplest
one so if I run this here I have a
triangle without a point which means
that it'll match to this default thing
down here at the bottom because what
happens here is that there's no point so
it can't really match that because it's
an old right so
deconstruct that so it'll find out that
well you didn't set the point on the
object so if I run this it'll say well
there's no point in running this code
unless you say that the the triangle has
a point as well now what happens now
what happens is that it'll match to this
thing down here which is triangle a B C
and where there's a point so if I run
this again here it'll hopefully print
out those values so that's pretty cool
now what happens if I say well a and B
are equal which isn't really that great
because it should have they should be
equal sorry if I do that we'll see what
happens this is ace not equal to B so
our triangle needs to have two sides
that are are equally long so if I change
that back to 10
it will then match this second one here
okay so of course is matches in order as
well now the final one here so they have
these preview compilers that you can
download but what's funny with them is
that they don't have all the features in
in all the different versions of these
new compilers so if you want to try
ranges and recursive patterns who
download one version and if you want to
try these nullable references you have
to download another one which kind of
makes it demoing these really hard so
let's just imagine that we have this
person here I'm initializing that to a
new person I'm saying print P here and
then what happens is that well in this
case here it's gonna say P dot name dot
length but I haven't set name to
anything so that's gonna be an old
string right it'll throw an old
reference exception if we look at the
person implementation here I'm saying
well this class here is nullable so this
this thing here is something they want
to introduce in in c-sharp eight where
you say well this everything is by
default non nullable but now we're
saying well this string is knowable
which in
I D then would say well P dot name here
can be can be null so you should
probably do this so you'll get some
information when you run the app so
they're trying to think about well how
do these improvements affect people that
work with these language features every
day if you just upgrade the compiler and
you have squiggly things everywhere
people are gonna be pretty upset so what
I want to do that and we don't want to
do what they do in Kotlin which is that
do this for everything which is kind of
a waste of keystrokes to do to scream
things so I can run this code here
because I don't have that compiler
installed but pretty much the only
addition is to have this nullable for
reference types as well or a little
ability so if you remove that it's not
null and if you haven't said it the it
will be very
it'll complain that it's not setting in
the constructor so if we had this and
ran this with a new new compiler it
would tell me that well you need to say
in the constructor that the name is is
set as well otherwise it won't compile
or you can probably turn those features
on and off alright so pretty much what
they're doing is that they're making up
for past mistakes so adding Knowle to
the language is probably a mistake
depending on who you talk to but I think
it's it's one of those things that have
broken a lot of applications out there
and cost a lot of people a lot of money
so there are a few more things that
they're going to try not to the language
we talked about this null reference type
here which means that if we try to set
the point in this case to null it'll
just blow up the application because
it's not knowable so you wouldn't be
able to do that one of the features we
didn't look at its record types now
record types it's just a way for us to
kind of express ourselves in a more
simple manner so in this case here we
have this triangle which is a shape what
if I can just say well this triangle
requires a B and C to exist and if we do
that we can get a lot of cool things
generated for us so if we introduce a
record type imagine that we got this
entire class generated
for us it would generate the constructor
it would generate equality checks it
will generate the hash code it would
generate the D constructor as well as
this thing called with method the idea
with with is that you have immunity in
each ability in your applications so you
can't change any objects so instead you
say well give me this object with X is
equal to 10 and that keeps you a new
reference so you don't impact any
current state that makes sense
I think that's pretty good but they
still have a long way to work to get
this to work in the there's a lot of
things in the studio that needs to be
up-to-date as well now I'm a little I
don't know weird out weirded out but
this thing the default interface
interface methods do we have any library
authors in here that do you like you get
packages just a few yep so you've
probably experienced that well you want
to update an interface and you add a
method to that interface and you kind of
upset everyone that's using your package
so what if we can say well I'm gonna
introduce this method which in my
interface and it has a default
implementation that means that you don't
have to implement that member in your
classes that implement the interface now
do you know why I don't like this
because it's kind of like doing multiple
inheritance all of a sudden you can have
all these different interfaces that have
all these different implementations for
things and you don't know where they
were coming from so I don't know I'm
torn between liking this and not and of
course you could say well I want to get
an ID and you could call get point on
that so I don't know it's it's probably
a great addition especially for library
authors because what I've seen happening
as well is that they create new packages
instead with the new interfaces and
people have to re-implement that as well
which is also headache but it's a nice
addition and then we're getting an old
co-listing assignment so we're getting
some improvements so instead of having
to write that we can say well
just initialize X if y if it's no right
so don't do the assignment unless it's
null which is kind of nice but again I
think they could could have just used
one question mark and then we might be
getting negated condition if statement
so these features that I'm talking about
now they've been on the kind of the
champions list for a long time and
talked they've talked about these
features for a long time before but I've
seen them come off and on the the
approved features to the language but I
don't trust them to to add these
features until I see them in Visual
Studio so negated condition if
statements allows us to more simply
write this code here for instance we
could say well if shape is not triangle
or if if not shape is triangle or on
less shape is triangle so this is kind
of something that they're they're
playing with I don't know which one I'm
liking best I think that the last one is
pretty nice does anyone agree with me
that the last one is the best everyone
no I'm just kidding again they're adding
things to allow us to write less null
reference exceptions right so in this
case here we can say well if task is not
null we want to wait the task which
returns that otherwise it returns null
but what if we can just say well a wait
exclamation mark task and that just
solves that entire thing for us because
if you try to await on something that's
null it doesn't really it's not really
happy when you do that so kind of wrap
this up these different language
features especially ones that I've
talked about in c-sharp a I can't
promise that they're all coming except
the ones that will looked at in Visual
Studio that would probably add the
pattern matching improvement and the
Topol improvements and the ones that we
have for seven point one two and three
they're already out there so you can
play around with them as well already
and I think that the idea of them
rewriting the entire compiler and doing
that Rosling project has proven to be
pretty a pretty good idea
but you know the compiler is just one
part of the entire thing in the entire C
sharp and VP and F sharp ecosystem we
also have the runtime and so forth and
if you rewrite the runtime or out things
to the runtime you have even more
options what you can do with the
compilers but these are some of the
features that you might have missed in
c-sharp and I hope you've enjoyed this
and on your way out please do leave a
vote and if you have any questions I'm
available here afterwards if you want to
talk thank you so much